you helped me win the iron throne now
help me keep the damn thing
if there's one character from westeros
who
is almost a direct lift
from the real life wars of the roses
it's got to be robert baratheon
you have this king so adept at what he
does that he's able to grab the crown
in robert baratheon's case from the mad
king in edward fourth's case
from a mad king who was henry vi but
once he's got the crown
he has to face up to his own problems
now in in the case of robert baratheon
edward iv those are pretty much
personal what we now call issues edward
was a great warrior
but once the battles were over he
couldn't keep his breaches
laced up and drink and whoring were his
downfall
robert baratheon was known
for his drinking his luxury excessive
eating
but also his success in battle and these
are all things that edward the fourth is
known for as well
i need you ned i have a son you have a
daughter
we'll join our houses marriage in
westeros is
uh to some extent based on marriage in
the in the real middle ages
or even in certain ancient cultures
marriage was a form of political
alliance
it was a way to bind two families
together so medieval nobles would
consider their marriages the way a
corporate ceo
might consider a merger the young wolf
has lost half his army his days are
numbered
theon greyjoy murdered both his brothers
that makes sansa stark the heir to
winterfell
you will wed her bed her and put a child
in her
tyrion will do us his bid as will you
what do you mean we'll marry solaris
i will not the boy is heir to high
garden tyrion will secure the north you
will secure the reach
no i won't do it but you will
individuals
are in a large part defined and
often struggling against what they've
been born into
i can't marry him you can't make me he
is a traitor
a murderer you're not marrying roose
bolton
no you'll be marrying his son and heir
ramsay
i will starve myself i will die before i
have to go there
i won't force you to do anything when
you look at the wars of the roses
there's one character elizabeth of york
who's sort of traded
a little bit the exactly the same way
that sansa stark is
so elizabeth of york basically became a
political pawn
between different families all circling
the real
english crown please let me go home i
won't do any treason i swear
mother says i'm still to marry you so
you'll stay here
and obey sansa may be based on
a specific character but she may also
just be an amalgamation of
every single daughter of every single
king
of every single kingdom in the entire
middle ages from the beginning to the
end
daughters were used as bargaining chips
i know how to play a man like drogo i
give him a queen
and he gives me an army i don't want to
be his queen
i want to go home we go home
with an army with carl drogo's army